we do have a Wonder Liang after his
victory against Alex Letterman a
Wanderer first of all congratulations uh
a difficult tournament after this point
especially the game yesterday against
elshon tell us a bit about how did you
approach this uh game with the white
pieces of gasoline yeah I had two piece
sets to do after my game with Alshon so
I just spent the night working on
homework didn't really have much time to
look at anything really and
um yeah I was like out of book after
move three so
um basically like I I I I didn't really
know what to do against the slav
um and I guess that just kind of happens
when your sub 2700 level you know I mean
you like to watch the guys at Corona but
sometimes you have to look at my games
just to see the struggle for the rest of
us so yeah I saw Jeffrey played Queen C2
against Darius so I was like okay
Jeffrey used to be 2700 probably it's a
decent move
um and yeah we've got some normal
position I think so you were playing
from memory yeah from Distant Memories
of the past watching a game yeah I don't
think sure I'll pay Quincy too yeah I
was I was well out of books so I thought
like I would just play something random
um maybe lose this game quickly and then
get back to homework again
so you know I was really surprised when
actually I got a decent position because
I don't think Queen C2 is the main move
but it's it's a move yeah it looks like
a move at least five G3 yeah okay this
apparently is some kind of line and yeah
A4 looked interesting the idea is that
in some lines after Knight B6 and then
maybe my D4 Pawn is hanging so if I
provoke A4 A5 then like his nylon B6
would be very loose
um it's going to be three yeah here I
might have like Knight H4 rookie one
something like that
um yeah I was just happy that he wasn't
blitzing anything out anymore so
um I didn't hang a piece and basically
you took him out of uh yeah his
preparation for sure yeah so here I mean
probably he's equalizing after takes
takes Bishop B4 but at least I have my
Pawn A5 so I have like some space
advantage and also the center is very
secure
um and yeah I think basically it was
equal until I'm not sure he played E5 um
if you keep going yep
so yeah just trade some pieces and I
think this is totally fine yeah and here
he played E5 which I wasn't I didn't
really understand what the point was
um I thought maybe if he just played
like Knight B6 instead or I mean Queen
takes A5 it's very normal position I
mean yeah yeah the a pawn is a little
weak but
okay you should be able to hold and and
like a lot of cases like the five on
four is not even that yeah yeah
especially if like let's say I have e45
then like that's definitely holdable so
absolutely yeah I think probably he was
he was just a little overconfident
um
you know when I got the wild card
I sort of thought that the stainless
chess club like always needs a punching
bag so it looked like um yeah you
probably thought like I blended
something but I'm not too sure um and
after d takes E5 like he thought for
quite a while so
um yeah normally that's not a good sign
when you're like sacrificing pawns
pretty sure if you're 2600 you can never
call yourself a punching bag you're into
A2 Queen takes A2 and you felt quite
comfortable with the uh huge majority on
King side yeah sure I mean it's probably
it might not be winning but I think
practically it's just very hard for him
to defend this like he has to generate
counter play in like very unexpected
ways and I think probably like after
Bishop e394 it looked maybe almost okay
for him
um like yeah maybe here in Knight C3 or
something
and then Rook CA and try and trade a
pair of Rooks because yeah once he
trades the Rooks then um like Bay Pawn
yeah basically like I I would much
rather have two Rooks on the board so
that when Rook gets active and here like
okay he has Loft counter play
um but yeah I think basically yeah and
especially after Knight D6
um yeah he allowed Rook C7 and the
center Inc and like okay now it's entire
queen size falling apart
um absolutely so yeah I mean probably
just an off day for Alex because yeah
this play seemed a little strange in the
middle game but yeah still happy to get
the win very happy to get the winner
wonder you mentioned that you're doing
homework how do you balance your
academic career as well as your chest
Korea yeah I think at the moment I'm
much more of a student than a chess
player
um you know it's really funny because I
was going to come in here and talk about
how it's really hard to do everything
and like school is taking a lot of time
from my preparation but then I see
Jennifer in the other section also in
college wearing all her games and like
that excuse does it hold up that much
water anymore
um probably got to ask her how it's done
from my end yeah I mean I would like to
play better chess going forward but I
guess we'll see like and what do you
study in college at the University of
Chicago
we're taking various classes right now
the major is still undecided so you know
plenty of directions to go still
figuring it out and you mentioned this
tournament uh that you're going to miss
school to your professors what was uh
their response
um most of them said like the first line
was like congratulations and then the
second line was like I still expect you
to turn everything in
so you know not much you can do on that
end but yeah still glad to be here
um it's a good it's a great event and
and yeah you know it's it's been an
enjoyable experience thus far I wonder
congratulations we'll see you in the
remainder of the games thank you uh
lovely interview there I can understand
that this